for them to go up against the
juggernauts in this street like fortnite
the way epic moves behind fortnite the
whole the whole company is behind this
machine right the way that they're able
to switch it on the Fly they can drop
the game down they can do a down time
for an hour and do an update that yeah
that's what I'm saying they cannot do
that single player and compete with
these companies right they can right
because even even fortnite dropped
fortnite save to save the world right
push that thing to the side because they
they focus on the multiplayer it's so
it's either or
Halo isn't relevant
I know that sucks it isn't relevant to
our children today
right and the reason why I'm saying that
is and this is where I was going to give
you flowers it solved this bag oh no I'm
just I I don't I don't like being right
about this this is true this is true to
the fact that any kid that I know from
eight to let's say 15 to 16.